those who are new to my channel I have a
YouTube channel every sub helps
tremendously trying to get to 500k by
December which is super ambitious
but I think we can do it I think we can
absolutely do it
[Music]
and we have black against 1995 very
strong player
okay we're facing D4 which we have not
faced
in quite a long time I mean I think
we've only had one grunfeld game thus
far and those watching on YouTube who
might be aware of the Reddit discussion
that uh was happening over the last
couple of weeks uh where you know same
people are saying the grunfeld is a
great opening for intermediate players
others are on the opposite side of the
boat I'll address that in a little bit
more depth after the game but right now
let's focus on uh the play and on the
theory because this is a serious
opponent now as you guys know my
recommendation for the speedrun is the
grunfeld which is a risky recommendation
one that I vacillated on for a while but
I'm still happy with it so as hopefully
you know the main move here is Knight to
C3 then Bishop G7 leads to the king's
Indian defense and the move D5 initiates
the grunfeld so those two openings are
very much related Knight F3 is of course
also a possibility and it's important
not to play D5 here right if you play D5
prematurely then White's going to trade
and play E4 and the issue is that you
won't be able to take the Knight on c3b
because there is no night on C3 I'll
spell that out after the game so what
you want to do here is first fiancado
the bishop you have to wait for Knight
C3 and only then play the move D5 if you
want to play the grundfault properly
you're not allowing the king's Indian
here because white can't play E4 right
when white plays E4 you know that you've
allowed the king's Indian because you
can't play D5 here E4 simply leads to
Knight 64. so our opponent plays
a rather strange variation kind of
developing the Knight and then the
bishop in an order that I'm not too
familiar with now one General piece of
advice for openings is that when you
learn an opening system such as the
grunfeld it's very important not to be
dogmatic right people get into trouble
when they try to play the same system
regardless of what the opponent does
that's a recipe for failure because you
have to be flexible enough to react
appropriately when your opponent plays
something weird this is a little bit
weird because he's delaying the
development of the B1 Knight developing
it is very typical here so I'm already
kind of on guard and I'm not just going
to close my eyes and play the typical
grunfeld moves I'm gonna invest some
thought into perhaps modifying my
opening system which could be
appropriate given how our opponent is
playing so maybe a king's Indian setup
is better in this particular version and
you don't necessarily have to know all
of the king's Indian ideas to play it
successfully right that's this concept
of flexibility in the opening which I
think is one of the the reasons I don't
recommend the London system because that
teaches you that you can play the same
moves against absolutely everything and
get away with it which you can with the
London but can't and other openings so
tldr
we're going to delay the move D5 I don't
like D5 here because white can take and
stick the bishop on E5 and we definitely
don't want to trade our dark squid
Bishops early so let's start with the
most flexible possible move I I think
that's the castle right we're just
developing our pieces and seeing forcing
our opponent to put their cards on the
table so to speak and then we'll decide
whether we want to play a grundfeld
setup or maybe even we want to play a
benoni type setup and stick the C Pawn
forward especially because I'm looking
at the B2 pawn and I'm noticing that
it's weak so we might have some tactics
related to a discovery on that pawn so
to me C5 looks quite appealing our
opponent by the way isn't really playing
a pure London a pure London would be the
pawn on C3 rather than C4 so he's
playing some sort of a cross between the
London and the sort of Main Line right
which is generally not advisable but
there's nothing horribly wrong with how
our opponent is handling this
given the placement of the bishop on F4
I'm extremely tempted to play a king's
Indian setup because the king's Indian
set up against the bishop on F4 is
incredibly effective and there is a plan
here that I really really like which
involves starting with D6
now I'll play D6 and then people on
YouTube will be saying well what do you
mean you're recommending the grunfels
and now you're reverting back to uh what
I thought you would recommend but again
this all goes back to the concept of
flexibility you have to be ready to play
a different setup against let's say an
unorthodox opening Choice by your
opponent so I really like the move T6
here we're gonna play it and then I'm
going to show you a setup that I think
gives black a very good position against
the bishop F4 variation
yeah if you're a grinfeld player you
have to be able to play a king's Indian
setup if you're a king's Indian player
sometimes pushing the pawn two squares
is a much more effective way to play the
opening now the elevator pitch of the
king's Indian is that you put the pawn
on D6 in order to prepare E7 E5
in this particular version this is hard
to do and that is why white puts the
bishop on F4 white is making it
extremely hard for black to prepare the
E5 Pawn break so you might say well then
let's play C5 but C5 isn't all that
effective here because white can just
ignore C5 is a decent move here's the
setup that I really like we start with
the move C6 if you've seen King's Indian
games you will know that this move is
actually incredibly common because
typically the knight from B8 is
developed to D7 that's just how you do
it in the king's Indian so putting the
pawn on C6 does not really obstruct the
development what is the move C6
accomplished well you'll see what it
accomplishes on the next move we're
preparing a plan of Queen side expansion
which will also give our light squared
Bishop a nice developing square but in
and of itself this move also controls
some key Central squares it controls the
D5 Square it grabs a little bit of space
on the queen side so it's just a sort of
harmless way to improve the placement of
your pieces and Pawns hopefully this is
kind of making sense so far this is a
king's Indian setup as defined by the
pawn being on D6 rather than D5 which
would be the grunfels and we played the
move C6 so start thinking about what I
could mean when I say queen side
expansion how do we prepare a plan of
Queen side expansion what is the next
move likely to be I'm anticipating
Bishop E2 or Bishop D3
so RW Zagar is recommending a plan that
involves preparing E5 there's a tactical
flaw involved in this plan which I'll
show you after the game
yeah so we're preparing B5 now you
definitely don't suck at chess Wing
chess you name the right plan the plan
is to play B5 and expand on the queen
side but you can't play B5 immediately
because white has three Defenders on
that square B5 CB CB Bishop takes B5 and
you know we can play that as a Gambit
but there's no need for that let's play
A6 there it is A6 C6 and B5 which is a
pretty ubiquitous plan in a lot of
different openings like these three
particular moves building up a pawn
triangle on the queen side but the
general goal is Queen side expansion now
with the ultimate aim of developing an
attack of some sort on the queen side
and making white more uncomfortable
so we're preparing B5 Grizzly wolf asks
does this weaken the B6 Square
technically it does the B6 square is a
weakness by definition because it can't
be defended by a pawn but let me ask you
in return how is white ever going to
exploit that square right why does never
going to be able to put a piece on that
square especially after we play B5
because White's not going to have time
to play Queen B3 and Knight A4 and then
Knight B6 it takes three moves for white
to stick a knight on B6 and we can even
bring our Knight out to D7 at the right
moment to really reinforce that square
now of course you might be looking this
and saying well white is going to say
Over My Dead Body and play the move A4
which I'm kind of anticipating then
there's the sort of secondary part of
this plan
A4 creates a massive hole on the B4
Square which would be really nice as an
outpost for our Knight our opponent
didn't play it so I'll show you what to
do after the game Queen D2 is a little
bit of a weird move I'm not sure totally
what our opponent is intending perhaps
he's intending E4 and then Bishop H6 but
it's even more of a reason than to play
the move B5 just in time let's go B5 we
can play that without much thinking if
white plays E4 who can tell me how we
will respond to that move this is
another benefit of playing on the flank
is you're making it harder for your
opponent to play in the center yeah E4
there is of course the move B4
dislodging the Knight and winning a
critical Central Pawn on e4 yes white
will be able to take on B4 but that's a
fair trade that's a good trade for us
Central Pawn for a for a corner Pawn or
flank Pawn rather you might say well
okay so are we threatening the move B4
no we don't necessarily want to rush the
move before because it takes the
pressure off of the C4 pawn and it's not
like the Knight doesn't have any good
squares after B4 the Knight could stick
on A4 the B4 Pawn then becomes a
weakness and white gets closer to
putting the Knight on B6 so expansion
doesn't mean that you sort of blindly
move your pawns as far as they'll go you
can't win a game with a space Advantage
you want to do it in a kind of measured
way our opponent stops the move before
so it's ultimately a moot point okay now
we need to work a little bit on
developing the rest of our pieces we
have two pieces that are not developed I
mentioned when we were preparing the
move B5
that a positive byproduct of this plan
is that it gives this bishop
a nice developing square what am I
talking about
well of course I'm talking about the
bishop fianchetto and you might look at
this and say well if we've seen ghetto
the bishop the bishop is just kind of
biting on granite it's staring at its
own Pawn but later in the game we could
prepare further expansion with c65 then
the bishop potentially becomes a monster
and this is very standard in this line
so the other developing move that we
should consider is Knight B8 to D7 so we
play Bishop B7 and Knight B to D7 and
the benefit of Knight B to D7 is that it
does potentially prepare E5 let's not
throw that move into the garbage can
under a different set of circumstances
E5 can still be very strong but most
likely we're going to orient ourselves
to C5 we'll start with Knight bd7
I think because it prevents white from
playing C5 as g-dog points out if Bishop
B7 white has this move C5 and then the
bishop is is genuinely blunted
completely but wait a second I just saw
something no I think I saw an
interesting tactic let's go Bishop B7
if white plays C5 here and tries to
close our Bishop down we're gonna take
on C5 and then we're gonna develop our
Knight to D7 attacking the C5 pawn and
who can tell me what tactic exists after
white plays B4 in that position to
solidify the pawn and I see this because
White's Rooks are disconnected anytime
the Rooks are disconnected and you have
an x-ray you should be looking at this
tactic there was the move Knight E4 yeah
there was the move 94 and then we would
have been able to take the rook in the
corner that again that's a moot point
now because White's castled now C5
becomes a genuine positional threat
because it can be supported with B4 and
then our Bishop is is genuinely going to
be buried under the pile of rubble and
I'll show after this after the game so
don't worry too much if you're not able
to visualize this that's what the post
game analysis is for let's complete our
development
with the move Knight bd7 I really don't
see why not
I really don't see why not and we've
completed our development we have a nice
position
our opponent has also handled things
very decently
I actually think I had a better move
though I'm bumped I rushed it I there
was a move here that went after the
bishop pair which some of you have
suggested Knight H5 which I think we
should have played in this position but
9bd7 is also fine
um nothing nothing wrong with that move
what's our mid game plan for this setup
well it really depends almost entirely
on what our opponent plays next because
our opponent I think has two main ways
of approaching this he can make these
sort of General improving moves like
Rook ac1 you know or maybe Rook F to D1
then we will embark on one concept but
our opponent could also play this more
aggressively and play a move like E4 and
try to expand in the center our opponent
could also discharge the tension with C
takes B5 then we would have to decide
which Pawn to recapture with so I'm not
thinking too much right now about what
our next move is going to be we're just
kind of waiting for our opponent to
reveal what his plan is so this is a
misconception that you know when your
opponent is thinking you have to know
what you're gonna play next you have to
have a clear plan in mind BS in many
positions your plan depends entirely on
what your opponent does and you should
spend your opponent's turn just sort of
making General observations that could
help you accelerate the process of
looking for a move so what sorts of
observations are we making well I'm
noticing that the bishop on B7 can be
cleared up with the move C5 the diagonal
can be open so that's something that we
should keep in mind now C5 does blunder
the B5 Pawn but we could potentially
take the pawn on C4 and then follow up
with C5 this is a very typical idea when
you've got the setup I'm also keeping an
eye on the possibility of E5 the queen
on D2 and the Queen on d8 are in a
standoff so there could be certain
situations where E5 is possible even
though there are more Defenders on that
square than there are attackers from
black side because maybe the queen id2
becomes loose in some line so I'm making
that mental note to myself of course we
could also play Rook E8 in order to
prepare E5 our opponent makes a general
waiting move H3 okay
so the way that I see it we have two
approaches we can continue playing the
waiting game with a move like rookie 8
potentially preparing E5 but I pointed
out that preparing C5 is more in the
spirit of this position and that's what
we're going to go for so again
if we play the immediate C5 we blunder
the pawn on B5 everybody should see that
white has three attackers and we would
only have one Pawn defending so before
playing C5 we need to discharge the
tension with BC
and you might look at this and say well
don't you leave the A6 Pawn isolated
isn't this Pawn now a big weakness
can't argue with that it is a weakness
it's isolated but it's not the most
important Pawn in the world and it's
very hard for white to attack this is
what I think a lot of people miss when
they think about weaknesses they think
okay a weakness is bad yes but you also
have to ask yourself how easy or hard is
it for your opponent to actually attack
that weakness the pawn is defended
nicely by the bishop and The Rook white
can't attack it even if he tried and
even if we lose that pawn it's really
not the end of the world so weakening a
corner Pawn is rarely a reason like not
to do something
there must be other drawbacks for you to
be dissuaded from playing that one
so what what does the move C5 do well it
opens up the bishop why is that
important we're already threatening to
take the Knight on F3 and permanently
White's Pawn structure that's a
huge positional threat
D5 is correct our opponent closes down
the center leading to a sort of benoni
structure which is defined by The Pawn
on C5 and white spawn on D5 this is a
type of structure which arises very
frequently from the modern benoni I'll
show how that happens after the game we
can't waste time here because if we give
white a couple of Tempe what is white
going to do well White's going to play
E4 and expand in the center white will
be having the positional threat of
Bishop H6 we've already talked about the
the importance of maintaining our dark
squared Bishop here that's the soul of
our position
plus the bishop on B7 is like hey what
are you doing to me now I'm staring at
this Pawn but this Pawn on D5 is also a
Target and we can use that pawn to
assemble our pieces nicely on the queen
side I think there's an obvious move in
this position that I think we should
flick in because it doesn't do any harm
yeah I'm talking about Knight B6 let's
hit the bishop let's increase and
intensify the pressure on the D5 plot
and let's Force this bishop to commit to
a bad Square such as A2 where it's
really not doing anything other than
defending this Pawn there's certain
moves that you could really play without
knowing what your follow-up is because
clearly this move doesn't do any harm
so right now we're making it one move at
a time we're waiting for our opponent's
response and then we're calibrating our
subsequent play
based on what our opponent does
yeah well it would be nice if we could
play E6 which is common in the benoni we
can't do that if we play E6 we blunder
the pawn and you could say oh but then
we can take on F3 but you're gonna end
up giving two of your pawns away that's
not a worthy price to pay because
White's King is still pretty safe even
if white has to play GF
so E6 I really don't like also it
weakens the D6 Pawn as Aquila points out
okay so if you play the benoni and I'm
sure at least one person in the chat
plays the modern benoni the move that I
kind of want to play here and I have two
ideas so I actually will need to think a
little bit
the move one move that I want to play is
incredibly typical in the benoni and
that's the move C4 slicing off the
connection between the bishop and the
pawn and vacating the C5 Square which we
can use as an outpost
actually for the F6 Knight we could play
C4 and then Knight fd7 and Knight C5
putting pressure on various weak squares
in White's position so I really like the
look of C4 let's go for it again a low
risk move we pushed the pawn we blocked
the bishop we attack D5 and we force
white to play E4 without the move E4
white spawn would have been lost white
has no other way to defend D5 Falk asks
can't white play B4 here I mean B4 is
not a dangerous move it opens up the
diagonal and it blunders the pawn on D5
but we're not afraid of B4
now white has to play E4 our opponent is
taking a while here not really sure what
okay E4 exactly yes
so now E6 is a more appealing move but
it's still bad because the D6 Pawn
becomes a serious weakness as a result
in fact we would lose that pawn E6 d e
we could go for some tactics there with
Knight takes C4 but I'm pretty skeptical
about that because we are going to lose
the D6 spawn pretty quickly after that
although it has to be calculated it's
actually not
totally clear-cut that E6 is a terrible
move here
so what is White's positional threat in
this situation once white plays E4 a
positional threat has been created which
we cannot prevent but we can take the
sting out of it and hopefully some of
you know this technique the threat is
Bishop H6 why is that a threat well that
forces the exchange of Bishops why does
it Force the exchange of Bishops because
the only way to keep the Bishops alive
is to duck with Bishop h8 but then we
would be losing the exchange so how do
we take the sting out of the move Bishop
H6 well we need to move the Rook first
so that Bishop H6 could be met with
Bishop h8 this is a very very standard
technique that is applied oftentimes in
the dragon and in other openings where
you feel Cairo the bishop and where you
have to keep that Bishop the health of
your position depends on your ability to
keep that Bishop alive
now our next few moves are probably
going to be Knight fd7 and then Knight
C5 and we're going to try to start
accumulating the pressure on White
Center and eventually I think the light
Square Bishop can be reignited if we're
able to play the move E6
Queen E2 okay
so obviously our opponent hits the pawn
on C4
that's fine
that's not such a big deal in fact I
would even consider sacrificing that
pawn in order to generate and get the
bishop pair we have a couple of ways to
defend that pawn the move that I really
like here is actually A5 I really like
the look of A5
what does A5 accomplish who can tell me
what that move accomplishes
it grabs a little bit of space on the
queen side but how does it prevent
Bishop takes C4 very nice very nice so
A5 Bishop takes C4 Knight takes C4 Queen
takes C4 we have Bishop A6 at the end of
the line skewering the F1 rook and the
Queen on C4 of course white can block
with Knight B5 but then the E4 Pawn is
going to be lost
are there alternatives to that move well
we could again consider the move E6 E6
might actually be an even better move in
this position
now what is it about E6 that I like well
why was E6 bad previously it was bad
because the D6 Pawn would have been lost
here the queen has moved away from D2 so
E6 is a lot more appealing
so let me calculate this for a moment E6
Pawn takes Rook takes
white has Knight G5 we bring the Rook
bag Bishop takes C4 D5 man that looks so
much fun
you know what we're playing in the
spirit of the benoni and that's an
aggressive opening an opening in which
opening up the center favors the side
with the more active pieces what I love
about the movie six is also that it
opens up the light script bishop and
eventually we want to do that anyway so
I don't see a reason for us to wait the
X-ray that The Rook exerts on The Queen
Is yet another reason to play E6
specifically here
okay our opponent takes immediately and
so we respond
now is this risky absolutely this is a
risky strategy for black
but look at how our pieces are breathing
now the bishop the Knight The Rook
attack E4 our dark squared Bishop is
intact and safe
our our pawns weak yes they're extremely
weak that is the biggest flaw of our
position so what that means is we have
to conduct the initiative carefully the
more pieces get traded the more white
repels our initiative the likelier it is
that our active pieces are canceled out
by our incredibly weak pawns but Bishop
takes C4 I think is a mistake how should
we respond should we play Knight take C4
well no because the Rook is hanging so
should we meekly move the Rook away no
we have a better move why did we put the
Knight on B6 while we were defending the
C4 Pawn we of course take the bishop and
we do it without too much thought and
then we play Knight takes C4 again
playing quickly because there's nothing
to calculate here one two Defenders one
two attackers look at our Bishops and
how they're crisscrossing the board the
bishop on F4 can also get in trouble if
white plays Knight takes Knight we
respond with Rook takes Knight four king
the queen and the bishop
now technically the queen could drop
back to C1 in that position if you're
able to visualize and protect the bishop
but then we could bring the other Rook
into the game and the queen could get
into B6 and this is why openings like
the benoni and the grunfeld are so much
fun because you learn proper peace
coordination and you really begin to
appreciate the value of having active
pieces which sounds like a meaningless
cliche but that's incredibly important
as a beginner and early intermediate
says why not take with the bishop well
because the bishop is a treasure it's a
treasure because it attacks the Knight
on F3 and in general having the bishop
pair in an open board is good
so we we don't want to give away that
Bishop for free Bishop takes E4 white
would take with a knight or white would
even have Knight G5 four king the rook
and the bishop that would be an even
bigger reason not to take with a bishop
here Knight to D4 okay that's a good
move it's a really good move
but nothing that we can't deal with
so what does this move do well it
attacks the queen it attacks The Rook we
cannot play a move like Rook C8 here
because white takes the Rook anyway
simultaneously hitting the queen so we
do need to move the Rook Bishop takes D4
we're not even talking about because
there's no way that I'm giving this
bishop away without a fight where should
we go with our Rook well we should just
move it back to E8 why not to E7 because
that walks into various Tempo moves like
Knight T5 and Knight C6 and we also want
to open up the diagonal keep that
diagonal open for our Queen
so I don't see a reason for us not to
bring the Rook back to E8
uh D5 didn't work D5 Knight takes C6
same reason that Rook C8 didn't well
that's why I pointed out that line
D5 Knight takes rook and that
simultaneously hits the queen so then DC
Knight takes d8 and at the end you're
gonna be down in exchange
so when you're considering a threat on
your piece don't just say oh he's
attacking The Rook so I can
counter-attack their Queen you also have
to understand what happens after the
Rook is captured does that create any
additional threats does it attack your
queen in this case it does so you know
that counter-attacking your opponent's
Queen isn't a good idea Knight T5
I was a little bit worried about this
move
but now that I look at it a little bit
closer I think it might be losing the
game
now what is the first thing that I see
when I look at the 95 well what I see is
that both of our Bishops are making
contact with both of our opponents
Knights this is a situation that I have
ex have talked about before it's a
situation that makes it very likely that
we can make a move that will separate
one of our opponent's Defenders from
their pieces because the queen is
defending both of the knights so
logically what type of move are we
looking for well perhaps a move that
attacks the queen because perhaps the
queen will not be able to move to a
square where it can defend both Knights
at the same time mathematically there is
no such Square in existence well there's
C5 but it's control so even without
calculation you should be able to come
up with Rook C8 on the basis of your
intuition alone
now the line doesn't end here the queen
can move to a square such that it
attacks one of our minor pieces now the
Knight is protected by The Rook so Queen
E2 is not effective Queen D3 blunders
the Knight on D5 Queen A2 blunders the
Knight on D4 but there is the tricky
move Queen B3
what does Queen B3 accomplish well it
hits the bishop on B7
so you might say okay well Queen B3
let's take one Knight and then let's
take the other Knight but Queen takes
Bishop defends the other Knight
but don't stop calculating there Queen
B3 Bishop takes Knight Queen takes
Knight we have a winning move we
actually have a winning move in this
position as well I think there are two
ways to win a piece
but even simpler is Bishop takes D5
Queen takes D5 and Rook C5 to hit the
queen
it's not a queen trap the queen can drop
back to A2 it can drop to B7 doesn't
matter because the Knight on D4 is going
to be lost
now you might say well what about Bishop
takes D5 Queen takes D5 Rook C5 Knight
D4 to C6 well then we just take White's
Queen because once white takes Our Queen
we just recapture the Knight and in
either case or up a minor piece
so just double checking yeah I think we
can take
so we give up our light Square Bishop
but we do it for the greater good and
Rook C5 wins the Knight that's it that's
why the queen is the worst Defender
something I've been saying since the
start of the speedrun it's what's behind
the rule
which states that you should do things
with a piece of lower value the lower
value of the piece the better it is as a
Defender
um it didn't matter though I mean white
was losing anyway
it was losing anyway
yeah Queen 66 is at least it keeps the
Knight alive right at least our opponent
defended the Knight
GG
um but that's not disappointing because
the game is over anyway we were winning
a full minor piece there's a lot to talk
about that was 24 moves but there is a
lot to unpack here
and we're going to do a little bit of
opening an also because I will admit I'm
not too familiar with how our opponent
handled the opening I've never faced
that before
so we're gonna see if I was right to
transition us into a king's Indian
position or whether it was possible to
still stick with the grunfeld okay so D4
Knight F6 C4 G6 previously we faced uh
sort of fianchetto structure a game that
I still haven't analyzed but I will
still put that out
Knight F3 so as I indicated after Knight
C3 the grunfelt is uh D5
after C takes D5 Knight takes D5 white
generally occupies the center and it's
very important that black has the move
Knight takes Knight which affords black
a Tempo that is used to fiancato the
bishop and then we play C5 and we chip
away at White Center this is the
mainline ruinfeld and I'm sure that
we're gonna get uh the mainline grunfels
in subsequent game so I won't talk about
the theory here right now let's focus
instead on what our opponent did so
first things first why is D5 a bad move
here it's because after CD well Queen
takes D5 is just crap because you walk
right into Knight C3
Knight takes D5 white plays E4 and
Knight takes Knight now wait a second
there's no Knight takes Knight so our
Knight has to slink back to a very
passive Square such as B6 and white just
gets excellent development white gets a
Tempo to prevent Bishop G4 and what you
will find is that in a position like
this the standard groonfeld move C5 is
terrible because white just takes the
pawn and hits the Knight you should be
able to see that this is not the same as
C5 with the white Pawn on C3
can you speak us why not Knight F6 well
Knight F6 Knight C3 and again after
Bishop G7 your pieces are stumbling on
each other this bishop is just staring
at the Knight and white center is left
completely intact it's unattackable yeah
also E5 with Tempo is annoying
so that is why here you play Bishop G7
if the moment white plays Knight C3 to
play the grunfels you go D5 and again if
white takes it and plays E4 then you're
able to play Knight takes C3 and C5
um
and again we transpose to the mainline
grunfels
hopefully that makes sense now you might
say well why do we need to rush with D5
I play castles that's my main move but
after E4 you get into the main line of
the king's Indian defense which is
characterized by pawns on e4 D4 and C4 a
little side note a lot of people get
confused between the Pirates or the perk
and the King's Indian defense there's
one big big difference in the pierce the
pawn is on C2 in the king's Indian the
pawn is on C4 that literally is it right
the Pierce is like the king's Indian
against one E4
so it's like playing the king's Indian
but there's a big difference here the
pawn is on C2
here the pawn is on C4 you can see
otherwise the position is exactly the
same I guess after Knight F3 Bishop G7
but this
ostensibly small difference actually
makes a huge impact on the development
of the position that's why the Pierce is
a much worse opening objectively I think
than the king's Indian the main reason
is that with the pawns still on C2
White's Queen side is intact which means
that a lot of lines in the Pirates
involve White Castle in Queen side just
like in the Sicilian for instance Bishop
E3 castles Queen D2 followed by Queen
side Castle is one of the most dangerous
weapons against the Pierce hopefully you
can understand that with a pawn already
on C4 the queen side is a much less safe
place for whites King so that basically
eliminates a whole host of possible
responses also the Light script Bishop
finds it harder in the king's Indian to
develop to an active Square here the
bishop can be developed to C4
okay also there's the Austrian attack
which is similar to the four pawns
attack in the Austrian attack white
plays F4 one of the most dangerous
systems against the Pierce meanwhile the
four pawns attack against the king's
Indian which is Knight C3 Bishop g70 46
F4 is a dangerous line but it's not as
dangerous as the Austrian attack because
here white over extends his Center White
has four Pawns in the center hence the
four pawn attack but black has very
effective ways to chip away at that
center with C5 and E5 so anyways I could
talk about this forever let's focus on
the game
Knight F3 Bishop G7 and our opponent
plays this odd move Bishop F4 kind of
some sort of weird londony type setup
I'm gonna check the engine here to see
what Mr stockfish likes us to do which
is always a good idea when you face an
unfamiliar opening
okay so I had a suspicion that this was
the best move
the engine does approve of castles and
D6
the move T5 here might seem very
tempting because after C takes D5 Knight
takes D5 you hit the bishop with Tempo
but who can remind me why this is
actually a lot less effective than it
appears the engine confirms this white
is slightly better in this position
what does white do
no not Bishop G5 Bishop G5 is innocuous
Bishop not E3
not E3 because then we get the bishop
pair and C5 wins a pawn because white
can't take dude Bishop takes B2 it's
Bishop E5
no guys G3 E3 that just gives up the
bishop pair and black is doing well
Bishop E5 is the reason this is annoying
so always remember you shouldn't give
away your grunfeld or King's Indian
Bishop without a proper reason to do so
here it's very hard to avoid the trade
trading and white is simply better
because what are what are you going to
attack White Center with now yeah you
can play Knight F6 but you've wasted a
Tempo you've played Knight takes D5 back
to F6 you've given white tempo for
development and black is slightly worse
here in the grunfeld you don't want your
knight to be on F6 you want the bishop
to have a direct line of fire to the D4
Pawn
okay so that is why I decided on a more
flexible approach sorry which is to
Castle delaying the movement of the
d-pawn waiting for white to put their
cards on the table
but the engine actually likes the
immediate C5 this is the engine's
preferred move
and I pointed this out during the game
C5 is very good because the B2 Pawn is
unprotected and after D5 the engine
actually proposes a Banco Gambit style
idea who can tell me what move that
implies when I say A benko Gambit style
idea if you know what the benko Gambit
is you'll know what move to play here
yeah B5 sacrificing the pawn in order to
separate White's Pawn chain
but more importantly open up the queen
side and how do you follow up the move
B5 after C takes B5 who can tell me what
the typical follow-up is it's A6 yeah
yeah it's A6 right so now you're trying
to get rid of the b-pawn why are you
trying to get rid of it so that the
queen can develop to B6 and have a
direct line of fire to the B2 Pawn
the classic benko Gambit is to play C5
which is the entrance to the modern
benoni while we're at it let me show you
what the benoni is the benoni is the
move E6 here and hopefully you're able
to see the similarity between this
structure and the structure that we had
in the game so in the game look at look
at the similarity it's exactly the
modern manoni structure with a Pawn on
T5 here it's the same structure white
plays E4 and life goes on this is a very
theoretical opening I won't delve into
it but the Banco Gambit is the immediate
B5 C takes B5 and A6 named after pal
benko Hungarian Grandmaster who recently
passed away he was US champion
and this is still a very reputable
opening white is better with best play
but if you want an aggressive line
against D4 you should absolutely
consider the Banco Gambit so in any case
if we compare this version
to the version in this position this is
an improved version for black because
we've already seen kettled our Bishop
and the bishop on F4 is incredibly
awkward it's it's neither here nor there
and the B2 Pawn is even more vulnerable
so how is the game likely to continue
well B takes A6 is likely and now the
engine gives the immediate Queen B6
because the A6 Pawn is not going
anywhere we don't need to recapture it
immediately and guess what white has a
very hard time to defend the B2 plan if
white plays B3 this is already winning
how is it winning well there's Knight
takes D5
oh and this is brilliant oh my gosh this
is an amazing line okay watch this so
Knight takes D5 should make sense to
everybody right but here's the catch
after Queen takes D5 it looks like black
has blundered because if we take the
Rook white takes our rook and you can't
trap the queen here you don't have
Bishop B7 you're actually losing another
minor piece but there is a ridiculous
computer move in this position which
wins the game for black I'll give people
a chance to find it it's really hard I
didn't see it at all I mean once it's
played you understand the reason
yeah in Russia the Banco is also called
the Volga Gambit
it's not Queen A5 check because that
doesn't do anything what does Queen A5
accomplish
still if you take the Rook white takes
the Rook it doesn't defend the Rook
it's not Knight C6 although you're very
close Knight C6 is good
but here white can intercept with Knight
E5
and the position is unclear
but you have the right Square
it's Queen C6 people are getting it very
nice it's Queen C6 it's not Rook takes
A6 because again white can intercept the
bishop it's Queen to C6
this is a double attack you're attacking
the queen and you're attacking The Rook
what is the purpose of that move Bishop
B7 Frankfurt airport April blunders the
bishop don't forget about the pawn on A6
white has to trade Queens because the
fight moves the queen then we take the
Rook
so after Queen C6 we play Knight takes
C6 and look at what the Knight on C6
does it prevents white from sticking a
knight on E5 so The Rook is now trapped
if you say oh let's give up a knight to
avoid losing The Rook you're actually
going to lose the Knight and lose the
Rook
if you say okay let's give up a night
like this black plays Knight takes E5
and white cannot prevent the further
discovery of Knight T3 or even Knight
back to C6
you have to move your knight if you move
it to C3 bang that's a fork
white has to take and another Fork on
The Rook Queen C6 is ridiculous that's a
GM level move but hopefully you're able
to understand the point
of that move so obviously B3 is not
forced and you might say well what about
Queen B3 right offering the exchange of
Queens well here you play Rook takes A6
another sexy move
and you say I'm happy to trade Queens
but first of all I'm going to recapture
your pawn and this position is horrible
for white because white is collapsing
White's losing a ton of Pawns here D5 is
hanging B2 is hanging and the bishop is
gonna be a monster and if white takes
the Knight on B8
x-ray defending the bishop then of
course black has Queen takes B3 and The
Rook is lost in the end so these are
dangerous lines which shows you how
strong the benko Gambit can be white
just doesn't have a good way of
defending the B2 Pawn the engines move
here is Knight to C3 which I don't think
a human would play
and after Queen takes B2 apparently
Knight A4 equalizes but this still looks
like a nasty position for white I would
play this any day of the week with black
I don't see any other good ways to
defend B2 if you play Queen C2 you drop
this Pawn which is not a pawn you can
afford to lose Queen D2 walks into 94
and again you have Queen takes B2 next
so this is actually the best way to play
you've you stick C5 in and then you
transition to a benko gamut style
treatment of course white can play E3
and keep the pawn on D4 but I think
cd484 and D5 is a very nice way to
handle this position because if white
takes it you get a beautiful isolated
Queen pun structure where you have
control of the square in front of the
iqb which as we know is almost always a
good thing so C5 is going to be my
official recommendation why didn't I do
it because I'm too obsessed with the
king's Indian and I kind of wanted to
show the idea with D6 c6a6 and B5 just
to add to people's collection of
knowledge about this position uh and I
I'll be honest I didn't fully appreciate
the power of the move B5 I saw this idea
out of the corner of my my eye but I
wasn't sure how much of an improved
version
this is over the regular Banco Gambit
and well you know what the answer is now
much improved but it's not unheard of
for me to play a Banco gamut style idea
I remember a king's Indian game that I
had some years ago where I won exactly
in this fashion I transitioned to a
Banco gamut style approach and I mean I
crushed the guy because it was such an
improved version here's the game
this is from World youth 2013 under 18.
my opponent was a pretty strong player
so this started out as a samish samish
Kings Indian with F3
and I developed a system
where the knight from F6 goes back to
open up the diagonal you play C5
now my opponent makes a mistake he
castles allowing my knight to get out
and allowing me to secure the bishop
pair which I do but first I decided to
play what move if you guys have been
paying attention this move should be
very natural especially because without
the light squared Bishop our light squid
Bishop has incredible prospects if you
can get it on A6 the move is B5
white has to play CB now we snap off the
bishop and we take back on B5 my
opponent takes back and you should know
what the next move is it's Bishop A6 get
the bishop out to the uncontested
diagonal hit the Knight my opponent
drops it back notice that A4 doesn't
actually help because you can pile up
the pressure on the knight in a million
different ways you go Queen B6 okay so
that's not scary my opponent goes back
here comes the queen Here Comes The Rook
just look at the pressure that my pieces
are exerting all of them Rook fd1 now
Bishop takes Knight which is a tactical
move positionally doesn't make sense but
tactically it does who can spot the
subsequent maneuver which causes White's
position to collapse why are we taking
that Knight which piece can jump into
the game now
and where does it go what's the final
destination for for it
it's not E5 you don't want to close up
the diagonal it's 95. oh yeah I guess
that's what you meant Knight to C4 is a
fork on the bishop and the pawn so the
bishop has to go back and now calm
move Queen B4 threatening to take on B2
if white defends then simply Bishop
takes Knight that's the problem of
having uncoordinated Rooks is this is
always going to lose
that's it my opponent went A3 and I
stick the queen right in that weak
square and even in the end game white
collapses because he's going to lose B2
and once he loses B2 my C Pawn is going
to decide the game because it's a past
Pawn Rook ABA finally I take the pawn
the Smoke Clears I stop White's pawn and
I just start pushing the C Pawn the game
is over C4 C3 C2 but the final detail
after night before Rook takes A4 this is
critical
if white takes the pawn The Rook swings
over to C4 and the Knight is lost
because this is a Perpetual pin and just
Bishop B2 dislodges The Rook
so my opponent went Knight T3 I trade
Rooks and what's the final move of the
game it's obviously Bishop B2 because if
the Knight takes then black promotes
otherwise we promote and win a full
piece so my opponent resigned here so
you know simple illustration of how
powerful benko style ideas can be
um yeah this was a very satisfying game
so anyways let's go back to the game
we've spent a lot of time on the opening
let's let's move move to the middle game
uh but hopefully this has been
relatively Illuminating so we decided to
play a king's Indian setup so again why
didn't I play D5 well again it's because
of this bishop E5 move which I felt
justifies the placement of the bishop on
F4 I don't want to trade dark squared
Bishops even if the computer says this
is equal after Knight F6 I felt like it
wasn't really in the spirit of what I'm
trying to do so we played a king's
Indian setup our opponent plays E3
we played C6 yeah Bishop F4 castles E3
uh D6 Knight C3 C6 yeah white plays
Bishop E2 not not much to say about
the way that our opponent is playing
this setup and of course A6 is the Crux
of our idea so who can tell me what we
would have done in response to A4 this
is very important because most people I
think would play A4 and you can't play
B5 there are too many Defenders on the
Square a rook is undefended
so how do we exploit the whole on before
yeah we play A5 we push the pawn twice
and then we play Knight A6 the night
before and black is a great position
Knight A6 let's say H3 we stick the
Knight on this beautiful Outpost and
then subsequently our plan can be for
example to prepare E5 how do we prepare
E5 efficiently well one way is to sit is
to move the Knight back to D7 much like
I did in that game this prepares E5
straight away because now you have two
additional Defenders on that square
black is a perfectly good position black
has a great King's Indian position which
you can largely play without knowing
what the ideas are you can play E5 and
then deploy the queen to E7 eventually
you're gonna solve the problem of your
light squared Bishop big sus asks why
not Queen B6 well that's just a one move
threat which doesn't do much it
threatens the pawn yes but here white
can defend with something like Queen D2
and you've sort of committed the
placement of your queen you want your
queen in the center because you want it
to be able to support both sides of the
board
right be very careful very wary of one
moveitis which is a a big enemy in these
types of positions I I don't like C5
because it creates an equivalent hole on
B5 remember that's why we played C6 to
defend the B5 Square this just gives
white an equivalent Outpost you know why
would you want to do that also white can
close up the center with D5 and with the
bishop on F4 it's very very hard for us
to open the center because the D6 spawn
is always going to be weak
so hopefully that makes sense from a
general standpoint white played Queen D2
okay we play B5 so again if white plays
E4 we obviously play B4 and hit the
Knight and win the pawn I think white is
slightly better here according to the
engine so that's true but but the engine
doesn't really appreciate King's Indian
positions no actually black is doing
great after B5 I just checked but after
A3 I think I made a small mistake
um I feel like this would have been a
great time for us to collect the bishop
pair and if you play the London system
which is unfortunate sorry I had to
refresh because it disconnected me if
you play the London system you should
know what this move is now in the London
system why does white play H3 early what
is the purpose of this move what is it
that you are taking the sting out of and
our opponent did this move making it too
late for us to initiate what I wanted to
do and so we played Bishop B7 what was a
suitable alternative here and it is the
top engine move I just checked
Knight H5 exactly you go after the
bishop the bishop can move to G5
but now we chase the bishop away H6
Bishop H4 and G5 very important note
Knight takes G5 you might say oh it
opens up a discovery on the bishop but
no you take back and again you're
attacking H4 and the Knight can just
drop back to F6 insufficient
compensation for the piece
Bishop G5 doesn't do anything we just
drop our Knight back so white has to go
back to G3 now importantly you don't
have to rush Knight takes two three
where is this bishop going
it's not going anywhere you can just let
it sit on G3 now the moment white plays
H3 then it's a good time to take the
bishop but the engine likes Bishop F5
actually wants to develop the bishop to
a different Square which is kind of
interesting and then eventually you take
the bishop on G3 when the time comes for
that
yeah Bishop F5 for example castles BC
Bishop C4 and again Knight D7 to prepare
C5 but I love this position with the
bishop air because the dark squared
Bishop is going to be uncontested so I
think Knight H5 is a move that you
should very often consider and occurs
frequently in London system type
positions
hopefully that makes sense now you might
say well okay but isn't yeah as Aquila
says a lot of people are put off by this
because you're weakening your king side
and you are weakening your king side
there's no doubt about that I can
probably show you some games where black
does something like this and then gets
checkmated those games happen very often
but remember that white is probably
going to Castle King's side here white
can't really Castle queenside because
look at the state of the queen side
we've got the pawn here we want white to
Castle Queen side we're gonna Checkmate
him and white when he castles kingside
essentially relinquishes the ability to
exploit the weak pawns now you could say
well could white stay in the center well
if white stays in the center and then
the Rooks are disconnected and how do
you propose that white exploits this
weakness it's much easier said than done
because Knight takes G5 never really
works white can't get a queen to H7 and
even if he could the bishop defends that
square the other Bishop defends h8 so
don't worry about these positions just
because the H file is open doesn't mean
that it's automatically Checkmate you
have to think concretely okay how can
our opponent actually exploit the
weakness of the king so for instance if
we take this position let's say y plays
E4 and chases the bishop away then takes
on G5 even if I gave you three moves you
couldn't Checkmate me even if you put
your queen on H4 these two mating
squares are very safely protected but
what would I do here with black I would
play E5 opening up a channel between the
Queens either white has to trade queens
or his Center collapses entirely so as
you get to a more advanced level 1800
you have to start thinking more
concretely about the ramifications of
your moves and you shouldn't rule
something out just because it has a
drawback because at this level things
get more complex at a lower level games
are decided by global thinking blunder
right and you can largely play moves
that don't contain any drawbacks at this
higher level you can't win a game you
can't make an omelet without breaking
some eggs so you have to start
developing a concrete ability to compare
the pros and cons of each move which is
incredibly hard
I wanted to show two other things before
we move on to very instructive Games
first I wanted to do a search
and to see if I could show you on on the
fly a game in which black did this and
then lost uh can't Crash and Burn to
show you that yes you know these moves
contain their drawbacks and sometimes
it's too much which is give me a second
here's a game from 1995 naderhanov is a
GM and this is a very similar position
to what we just had guess what he plays
oh he plays G5 and Knight H5 now
obviously the problem with this move
isn't the black gets checkmated White's
already castled kingside who can tell me
the blunder that black has just
committed it's not like the biggest
blunder in the world but it lost him the
game ultimately
what's the problem with that H5 here
and don't just say Knight takes G5
because okay Knight G5 Knight G3 is what
he was relying on but what detail did he
overlook
what detail did Black overlook
no not Knight takes F7 Knight F7 you can
actually even take the bishop with Chuck
and black is up two minor pieces it's
not Knight takes F7 it's F takes G3
it's F takes G3 which is taking away
from the center is a move that's often
missed and look at the bishop on F5 it's
hanging so black not only loses a pawn
but his entire King side is also
shattered so F takes G3 is what black
missed and white won the game as you can
see by the one zero okay so that's one
one example
let me see if I can quickly find another
where black in fact gets checkmated
okay here's here's one where black
eventually
oh it was a sick game actually just a
moment
just a moment setting it up
yeah I can see the same blunder being
committed very very frequently with f
takes G3
okay this is super nice
this is super super nice and I'm not
totally sure that this was sound so very
similar position
just a second
very similar position and then I'll show
the third game that I wanted to
illustrate an important concept
okay here we go this is not a well-known
game I don't know these players but it
doesn't matter that the concepts are are
more important so in this position black
plays uh Knight H5 okay
and obviously as you know white plays
Knight takes G5 black plays Knight takes
G3 and black does not have a bishop on
F5 the problem here is this intermediate
move Bishop H7 check this is a brilliant
move
king h8 take the Knight notice that
white takes up the F Pawn anyway to open
up the Rook now the bishop drops back
what's the problem the problem is that
white threatens Maiden two and I'm sure
the black was relying on the Move Knight
F6 but simply Rook takes F6 and the game
is over
Queen H5 and queen G7 is checkmate in
Queen H7 that is so instead black plays
Bishop H6 to open up a running Square
for the king
but white brings the Knight into the
attack and then the queen into the
attack and white finds a sexy crushing
move in this position who can spot it
it's I don't even think it's the best
move I think White had a move here that
one immediately but the concept was
correct
yeah well Knight takes D6 is what white
plays I think Knight takes G5 is even
stronger
uh White plate Knight takes D6 same
concept everywhere if black takes then
you obviously just get checkmated
but Knight G5 also threatens a fork on
E6
so black just can't it's overwhelming
after Knight D6 black could Stave off
defeat for a couple more moves but as
you can tell I mean it just gets totally
demolished uh completely and totally
demolished yeah wow this is really nice
or F7 at the end and it's Unstoppable
checkmate
so anyways uh again everything has to be
taken very concretely last detour game
and then we'll finally move on to the
middle game I know this is pretty
extensive
but these positions are hard to really
describe without a lot of examples
because you know they're very dependent
on concrete phenomena in the position
this is a game that I played against
Alex or malinsky who's a GM hopefully a
lot of people have heard of him
foreign
this was not Tulsa this was uh Vegas I
think that's wrong but the year is
correct this is 2008. here's what
happens
we have a king's Indian
and your malinski plays the system with
H3 and Bishop G5 which is still pretty
popular and I decided hey I was like in
love with the idea that I executed in
the game so I played c6a6 and B5 this
was a book recommendation Alex castles
and here I make a tremendous mistake
which was a mistake that I talked about
during the game what do people think I
played and we discussed this move during
our speedrun game I mentioned that it
was wrong and this is how I learned that
lesson oh H6 is good H6 is best
I would play H6 now
I played the premature B4
and here's what I allowed Watch What
Happens Knight sticks itself on A4
Knights on the rim are amazing I played
Knight fd7 trying to prepare the move C5
and then everything would be groovy
how does your malinsky stop all of my
ideas and just bury me under a pile of
rubble on the queen side what does he do
bang C5 black white play C5 this Pawn is
unattackable you can't attack it you
have nothing to attack it with
Queen A5 blunder z7
and the bishop parks on D6 look at
Black's position everything is buried
A5 he goes Rook C1 typical Soviet move
to reinforce this golden Pawn bang bang
I mean he just like crushes me here my
whole position is just totally
collapsing uh and I went on for 50 moves
I eventually I sacked The Exchange to
try to like I had a good night on D5 but
it's obviously like totally insufficient
compensation and eventually Alex like he
put his Knight on B6 and he won pretty
easily here so it's important not to
push B4 unless you have a very good
reason to do so that's how I learned
that particular lesson I didn't play
Knight H5 so in the game we focused
instead on
Queen side development which is of
course I think totally fine as well
so Bishop B7
our opponent castles Knight bd7 H3 still
not H5 was good but we played without it
BC Bishop C4 and C5 so hopefully this
idea makes sense but after D5 I think
black is worse objectively I think
practically Black's position
uh has a lot of life but I think there's
no question if you turn on the engine
which I won't do it will give a
significant advantage to white but I
don't care it gives white an almost
winning advantage in the benoni the
benoni has survived for 50 years and has
caused uh anguish to a lot of top
players because from a practical
perspective Black's play is very easy so
here we play rookie super important not
to allow Bishop H6 file this away in
your mental Rolodex of ideas if you're
trying to preserve your Bishop then you
want to move the Rook away so that
Bishop H6 can be met with Bishop h8
sometimes this bishop is so worth it
that you sacrifice The Exchange on f8
but there's no reason to do that here
because you have time for rookie one so
Queen E2 I already think is a very
serious mistake I think this actually is
the biggest culprit because it walks
right into the movie six it walks right
into that white had to keep the queen
here so that the queen aims at the D6
spawn what would I do here with white to
maintain the advantage I would play a
simple move like Rook a to D1 you might
say well why are we putting the Rook on
a closed file it's to discourage black
from playing E6 even further how would
we have played here I would have played
Knight fd7 to get the Knight around to
C5
white can flick this in as a way to
cramp black even further and actually I
think white can go directly for our
throat with Knight to G5 hopefully
you've seen this concept and then just
go F4 and try to go F5 and blast open
the f-file
these ideas can be wildly dangerous are
these Knight G5 F4 F5 Concepts uh
something else that you should be
familiar with if you you know have
senior fair share of Grand Prix attack
games or Sicilian games these ideas are
incredibly common but I could probably
even find some King's Indian games
where
let me see if I can find something where
this exact type of attack happens
so here's the game from the women's
Olympia in 1996. two strong players Zhu
Chan is a Grandmaster
so white plays Bishop H6 and watch what
white does bang bang white starts
accumulating pieces on the king side the
queen drops back why does it drop back
to prepare F4 exactly like we were
talking about black tries to do some
stuff on the queen side fails F5
Rook F1 get the Rook to the open app
file H4 keep accumulating get the Knight
into the attack and hear white finds a
brilliant tactic who can spot
the way to shatter Black's King position
also pretty typical idea by the way yeah
Knight F7 is winning she plays Knight
takes H7 same concept different side
Bang
H5 not even Queen takes G6 because
there's no actual mate white uses the
pawns to generate even stronger of a
thread on G6 G5 black defends very
resiliently but in this position white
makes an incredibly sexy move it's a
retreating move
it's a retreating move who can spot it
and it reignites White's attack not
Bishop E5 because just D takes C5
there's not enough there Bishop C1 is
correct very nice you get the bishop to
the long diagonal your hand should be
reaching to play that move Bang
and this is over because white shatters
the center and the king is so wide open
all of White's pieces are in the attack
and white just like destroys black on
all sides of the board D6
and if you play Knight takes D6 I think
that Bishop F6 check is winning the game
because there's this check and there's
made on H6
King f8 Rook F6 is obvious Checkmate as
well
so this is all very very bad for black
and white wins the game just by taking
the rook in the corner Queen D5 by the
way look at this move
using the pin on the Knight
to Fork the king and the Rook winning
decisive material I can analyze this a
lot longer and maybe White's play was
not ideal but these types of ideas
should be considered very carefully when
your king side is a little bit open
don't forget the concept of like Bishop
H6 Knight G5 and then running the F Pawn
down the board to open up the FL here
white is quite a bit better so I think
this is how our opponent should have
played
the engine doesn't approve of Knight F
to D7 for that reason according to the
engine black should just play a more
docile move like Rook to C8 to keep the
Knight closer to the king side to take
the sting out of Bishop H6 Bishop h8
ig5 which is still very dangerous by the
way and now the other Knight should be
brought to D7
and after F4 you should start expanding
on the queen side the point of keeping
the Knight on F6 is so that if white
plays F5 white is not threatening to
take on G6 because the Knight stands
between the rook and the F7 Pawn
so something like this white is better
Queen E2 is an aimless move our opponent
focuses on the wrong thing it's not
aimless opponent sees the C4 upon but
this is not what white needs to attack
and after E6 I think the tables turn
immediately and black is already much
better so he takes C6 is correct
if white would have played instead
Bishop takes C4 then of course we play e
takes D5 and white collapses white loses
the pawn on e4 because if you count the
Defenders obviously black white has
insufficient Defenders because of that
pesky Rook on E8 x-raying the queen on
E2
so our opponent correctly took on E6 and
here makes the decisive mistake in an
already very bad position after Bishop
takes C4 our pieces just start breathing
and I don't think that white can
realistically hope to save this position
anymore
um although maybe there is some way to
keep the balance with computer-like play
but from a human standpoint I think
White's position here is already
indefensible how would I have played
with white in this position I would have
probably gone Knight G5
to attack The Rook but mainly to
solidify the E4 Pawn
and after after The Rook moves back I
would have probably immediately brought
my Rook into the game
and and hit the D6 Pawn black can play
D5 but the position is super complicated
here maybe get the queen out of the
X-ray and it's complete pandemonium
there might be a sack on F7 because of
the X-ray I don't know what's going on
here I think black is comfortable
but at least white gets realistic
chances to muddy the waters
um
so in any case
our opponent decided instead to take on
C4 which is a little bit impatient we
eliminate the bishop and then we take on
e4 I even think Knight D4 was a good
move I think our opponent was playing
very well up until the blunder which is
Knight to D5 this is of course the
decisive blunder because it loses a
minor piece and it puts the minor pieces
In Harm's Way how would I have played
here with white I have no idea I think
White's position is incredibly
incredibly dire I was briefly worried
about the look of Knight C6
because well because it slices off the
connection between the bishop and the
Knight and the last thing that we want
to do was black is to give up one of our
Bishops if we give up one of our Bishops
the intensity of our initiative is
greatly diminished and this position
just looks like a draw to me because
White's gonna win D6 wax gonna win C3
this is not how we do it who can tell me
a better and more patient move after a
knight to C6
using tactics to defend the Knight on e4
indirectly
not Rook C8 folks you're missing some of
the same stuff so this is a really good
teaching moment because the way you're
thinking about is like oh white takes
Our Queen we take white screen but you
have to calculate one move further you
have to make sure that in the resulting
position nothing is hanging here this is
hanging
and what's funny is that after Knight
takes C3 opening up an attack on the
bishop white has this move forking the
two Rooks White's gonna emerge up in
exchange
so instead I think there's two ways to
play here Queen to F6 is one way or even
Queen to H4
intending 94 Queen F4 and look at how
everything is hanging here
but even simpler is just to move the
queen up to D7 counter-attacking the
Knight
and this position looks fantastic for
black we keep our Bishop pair we attack
the Knight we attack the pawn our d-pawn
could start running up the board uh and
white is just getting destroyed here
white is just getting destroyed here so
Queen D7 is very simple and very strong
yeah Queen H4 is the more adventurous
move Queen D7 as the Russian Schoolboy
type of move or actually no scratch that
I blundered
I forgot that white can take on D6 sorry
that was my bad
white can actually even this I think is
unclear okay so I amend my
statement I actually think
okay the engine gives a ridiculous idea
here which is to play here
and then to play in Intermezzo that
preserves the default six Pawn does
anybody see this intermediate move
I guess now that I set it up it becomes
easy but it's a really pretty move D5
yeah D5 deflection you force the queen
onto D5 and now you play Bishop C6
skewering the queen to the Knight
but unfortunately white has Queen to C5
which saves the Knight but still you
trade Queens you take B2 and black is
obviously much better in the end game
because you have the bishop pair in much
more active pieces wow Jesus so lots of
tactical subtleties here to explore
anyways I think Knight C6 would have
been a better practical chance it's the
top engine move 94 rookie 4 makes
matters worse maybe white could have
held it like this but here we just
accumulate the pressure with Queen E7
this threatens Rook takes Bishop by the
way because white will lose the knight
at the end
and this is in a very unenviable type of
position this is why you don't want to
look at an engine about evalu here and
so it's 0.4 black is slightly better no
right from a human perspective black is
not slightly better if you look at this
with your own eyes you should understand
how bad this is for white a situation
like this
uh so obviously after Knight D5 the game
ends we play Rook C8 and by the way the
there is a second way that we can win a
minor piece we did it in a very
straightforward way also good is Knight
E4 to C5 because this defends the bishop
attacks the queen and I don't see a good
score for the queen if it goes back to
C4 we drop the Knight back to E6 96 Fe
and white cannot save both of these
pieces at the same time
yeah so Knight E6 isn't too retreating
Night Moves by the way Knight C5 and 96.
white doesn't have anywhere else to go
if he goes back then we snap off this
Knight yeah Queen c496 96 now don't take
the queen again don't just automatically
take a piece because white is more or
less alive after Knight takes D it's
still probably losing but F takes C6 is
much simpler
can the Knight cover the attack no
because we have two Defenders on that
square
and the game ended after okay our
opponent blunder the queen but obviously
it didn't matter because the queen has
no way to move back and defend the
knight at the same time and Knight C6
here we do take the queen because at the
end we just win the night
that was uh an extensive analysis
session I know that was a lot and it
might have been overwhelming at certain
points but hopefully it teaches you a
little bit about the sort of King's
Indian setup that we played
the main takeaway from the opening is
that you need to be flexible if you want
to be a real opening expert you you need
to amend your opening approach based on
what your opponent does even if you're a
grunfeld player it doesn't mean that you
blindly play the same setup in every
single game you have to be able to make
small changes such as okay here a very
good approach would have been to play a
benko style opening we decided to play a
king's Indian style setup and you
shouldn't be that scared of playing
something a little bit new because if
you follow common sense you can
generally go a pretty long way and if
your opponent is playing something
offbeat then they are generally not too
familiar with openings either and you
should be fine
and again this will be on YouTube so you
can watch it more slowly and follow some
of the lines on a board for example any
question
foreign
[Music]